[Music]
imagine having it all imagine being on
top of the world
monie homophobic a certificate or more
take a mocha review and no no no no try
it again only to give it all away
glittering in a game of boccie
we Lebanon agent Juan Badillo que - whoa
whoa
each other pinion to a church on the
other hand a turn your car wound up on
the sand Shh upon I an elaborate phone
once upon a time - Don's was the
undisputed best second player in the
world and then he vanished ten years
after his disappearance
- Don's came back but there were some
people in the scene who didn't even know
who he was there were some people who
didn't know what happened to him how
hard he worked the tragedy he overcame
but the people that did remember him
knew that a legend had returned
my god fighting games have never been
about the glitz or the glamour fighting
games are about glory and it's not just
because they have smaller prize pools or
smaller player bases it's that for years
finding information about the best
players in the world was almost
impossible in the days before streaming
a few names passed into legend for
Street Fighter there was Daigo Umehara
[Applause]
for Marvel vs. Capcom there was Justin
Wong
and for Tekken there was ku Don's video
music achieve you can keep your to shoot
each book in the early 2000s there were
few people in the Tekken scene like to
Don's
triangle play no game centaur elfanara
top computer you could install modulate
the pulmonary up at you looking at me
I'm Faisal to you Ginga
holding down like a sieve illusion game
whatever
that's my son money you can I got you
can I throw him out so she decide what
hands it's show me DVD my something he
was one of the best the dominant
tournament record in Korea and an Evo
title taken a change like a video named
Jay everybody of wool hunan skill was so
legendary in fact that some Tecna fans
love to tell the story about how in 2007
he won three separate tournaments at
electric cancel six
despite his wrist injury flaring up and
preventing him from using a fight stick
then the tournament standard unity
consider a channel by beauty Arirang
a tik engine we would tre team John take
one came John you take a day like today
come on in are you gonna steal my petrol
Harry time ago petal dance routine
[Applause]
[Applause]
but just after achieving that insane
feat Coonans disappeared he quit
competitive Tacony while the Korean
community remembered kou Don's his
legacy slowly faded in the memory of the
North American tekken sea and as the
years went on and players started to
retire the name coup Don's faded to see
cou Don's was winning tournaments during
what some call the Dark Age of fighting
games the name Dark Age isn't entirely
accurate though I know a lot of people
referred to into the Dark Ages I know
some people are frustrated with that
especially from other scenes like guilty
gear was still coming out with new games
Tekken was still coming out with new
games the thing is the year after coup
Don's left is when the pendulum swung
back Tekken 6 came out in 2007 and the
next game in the series Tekken Tag
Tournament 2 wasn't released until 2011
as a result the legendary Korean players
of the mid 2000 stopped traveling to
tournament's prize pool shrank
attendance dropped and Tekken mostly
receded to the darker corners of the fgc
and ku Don's for his part was too busy
living his life to dip his toes back
into Coonans did his 2 years of
mandatory military service and then went
on to finish his university degree
eventually he got a job as a social
worker working with disabled children
but in 2012 everything changed
qur'an's father passed away and the
trauma through his whole life out of
order crude Raj Shah Baba jiggle-ator
AHA I saw about a Toraja ship a jade
alabama no maharaja GUI go to two more
room to the church in each hub and the
Boca Peter Eckrich a single atom
watching a the chocolate store route or
a Buddhist or Chiba 7 mm guns you jiggle
around a border San Marino but you know
in Cebu Davao is a rock okeyday katashi
Pokiri she couidn't stand himself drawn
back to
takun but it wasn't the glory of
yesteryear that pulled him back in it
was a desire to find new purpose
but kou Don's couldn't just throw
himself back into the game
in fact he wasn't very good at all when
he came back gaming touchable yesterday
don't worry also enemy on Kelly Toma
digest home Pune ke to the Vancouver Iwo
game from Vitara but earnest IV they got
a round couldn't take I throw the man
who - mr. monk coupe and all the trouble
at all he got all 2k here than a mento
machine guns down Tony Dovolani anybody
saw in a minute because we age on in
Chariton sir I mean day Natasha Hanabusa
basis I happen to - Oh family girls that
are open they all assume that they are
Qataris are you gonna there tanky
Gannicus ago dad turned 20 2009 so you
[Music]
likely couidn't was surrounded by some
of the greatest Tekken players in the
world in one of the most brutal training
environments anyone could ever ask for
the green arcade green arcade is often
packed and is decorated with the
accolades and trophies won by the
players that go there you're going to
find some of the highest level of tech
and play over there futons grinded it
out he played every Friday and Saturday
working the rest of the week while
slowly getting himself back up to his
fighting weight and entering tournaments
again
[Music]
oh wow I just okay on top of my family
dies I'm done I mean I couldn't do
good answer by Jim about vs tottenham
hotspur give me the Caputo
[Music]
tada you killed all the white it
hi my name is Oh Oh ten mere recession
while he spoke temple doesn't get hot
cake anybody's
look at the crowd goes crazy qoodles
paid his own way to Tekken World Tour
events earning points and even winning
the Southeast Asia major what's gonna
happen going for the damage here goes
for the bid of four 401 to two down back
to anything's gonna do it right now
oh my god the final is 15 seconds left
that could I take the ladies and
gentlemen cuda secured himself a spot in
the Tekken World Tour Finals
man what a set make some noise ladies
and gentlemen what a sink and Koo John's
first tournament win on the Tekken World
Tour it's true winning our Asian
regional finals give it up to South
Korea's futons and you know who nods is
a legend obviously we first started
hearing about it back of the second five
days making a huge comeback that win
qualified him for the 2017 Tekken World
Tour Finals which would take place just
a month off of a full decade since he
last been in North America and Koo Don's
wasn't about to waste that chance the
legend the ghosts of tekken past he's
been doing this since the beginning kuma
doesn't have many opportunities here but
again whoo teleports out there
amana's what an impressive games from
Putin's boudin's has a big dojo it's
called Korea he's pretty good he's like
you didn't get launched there and the
house would cook field a deal right at
the tip Wow Wow
I mean if that doesn't deserve a
standing ovation I don't know what that
was such dominance impressive coolants
man she's it's such a treat watching him
play every time I feel like he does
something new every time I'm like man I
fit yeah it's like I'm a kid again the
download on AOL finish I can watch this
match from Korea again all the low laugh
deck and cute and convincingly - Oh /
Blackbeard very very nice work alright
looking at what we have on the winners
side we have JD CR and COO Don's
starting it off here we go oh it was
right in the damage is gonna be huge
here he's got the rage drive ya gonna
use it big damage not quite Oh
exactly you might not oh my god I didn't
even touch him he went over it Wow
unbelievable okay still in then there's
the counter in another mist electric
razor scraper seals the deal goes in my
cargo pocket oh boy Winky
the importer Lenny can you Bart how many
can you Bob that was incredible
oh my gosh all of that broken plate if
the stop can't even speak English right
now it's not going for the mids now all
the side steps here for jeans that's not
what you want to have it jump this is an
outrage
[Applause]
hugs me right at our chance not believe
my eyes
who does this moving on to our winner he
did finals give it up a food on
everybody but in the winners finals st.
not futons into the loser's bracket his
tournament life was on the line
it doesn't get much better than Jay DCR
and demands and he's created a quite the
situation for himself not over oh my god
does your body with Danny oh my gosh hey
remember me I'm that same guy three
times in a row don't forget my god I'll
never forget it don't forget that
feeling when you want the merely this
familiar let me charge oh man good bra
sweet they're two brave bunnies knock
them down okay either be careful heist
at that time whoa whoa JT's your Oh
oh my god calling the toilet so many
times can you guess right mark
oh the woulda cites them early on who
did the wall we're limited Oh
he's here to play are you not afraid
GBC are still alive oh he went free oh I
can't believe they're so great these
guys are playing out of their minds
right now
oh he's gonna take the wall Oh enough
time what's he gonna do to my little
timeline come on with it there's no time
left and that that is gonna do it
what away for JDC are the ends for JCR
that's standing oh look at the crowd
standing ovations hutongs me JDC are to
make it into the grand finals and then
ran it back against st. defeating three
to one to reset the bracket it all comes
down to this echo fox st. and Coonans
both top players from south korea
battling it out for the world
championship whoa can't let the step
this up going for the back one I've
never seen someone damn I've never seen
someone filled with Jack so well as to
dance right now oh and that is always a
comment back to here with the machine
was pursued that we're gonna need such a
miracle oh my god a gun it's not much
more of a miracle laughs OH
oh I don't think either button at all I
mean he got so many miracle comebacks
oh my god did you see that
[Applause]
fishing for the downpour - no time
what's gonna do and you can think he's
gonna have to go low there's no time
left
Oh oh god that's crazy my god oh stop
yelling oh my gosh he's gonna get it
he's hit again
Oh
Wow the pop oh god this guy the last
time qu Douglas in America was over 10
years ago for electric on c6 so it's
been over 10 years since you see the
mirror and he is still rocking Templeton
this is a different age man date is on a
mission I don't know if you guys saw
that I just got a real victim something
that very same on that [ __ ] Wow
with I mean in in one breath look at
that things have changed for to dance so
much oh you can't let this happen
he can't think that this could possibly
have a look at him trying to get him to
of course hit with the bigger one the
biggest the big boy combo
Marcus standing up just like that
who does one round away
being world champion the range oh this
one does so much damage so huge so
touched everyone's touching torsos
congratulations to the nuns from South
Korea here's your 2007 Tekken 7 world
champion back from the grave and relay I
want you to step up now make some noise
for your attacker World Tour Finals
champion
[Applause]
this man has come a long way this man
has come a long way raise that bad boy
up there you go in the years since that
win Coonans has remained on top of the
Tekken scene he placed second that Evo
2018 and the Tekken World Tour Finals
that same year I want you guys to make
some noise for a good friend of mine and
your 2017 take a world tour champion he
came in second make some noise for you
why use very oh this man is ridiculous
and though he spent most of 2019 on the
sidelines he was a true gaming
Invitational in March winning $60,000
one of the biggest prize pools in Tekken
a history genetics
[Applause]
[Music]
in South Korea but that 2017 finals wind
is what put ku Don's back in the
conversation so toward the end of t v dr
who dogs having a lot of trouble you
know playing yet wrist issues and
everyone thought this was the last we're
gonna see you went to the military but
he's made a comeback years played
legends never he is gonna be on the
biggest stage for Tekken 7 because after
a decade of soul-searching grinding and
training kunos found himself back on a
decade changes a lot of things but a
champion is always a champion that's at
the Royal Gorge app now that your Tekken
World Tour champion thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub buddy and bring that
notification fell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]